if you've been living under a rock or
simply made the wise decision to spend
last weekend enjoying time with family
gardening or doing whatever it is normal
people do you may have missed a rapid
sequence of events that is almost
certainly secured a landslide for K's
labor party at the next election it
started as political crisis increasingly
do with a politician who was prepared to
say something that is extremely
controversial by virtue of being true s
braan then Home Secretary penned an
inflammatory article in the times on
Wednesday in which he made a few
statements of the bleeding obvious what
was it about her commentary that so
disrupted The Fragile fabric of our
society what did she say that had the
mediate Elite so incandescent with rage
choking on their kinoa salads as they
tweeted their way into an aneurism
Braverman dared to suggest that the
police are not enforcing the law in a
balanced way as an example she raised
the disparity between the way BLM
protesters were police during the summer
of 2020 when coppers routinely kneeled
in front of them and the way the
anti-lockdown protesters were treated
only months later when the police
kneeled on them so far so inflammatory
she also went on to say that the public
expect to see upcoming anti-israel
protest in London properly policed boo
but how did we get from braverman's
article to prime minister Rishi sunak
sacking her appointing David Cameron yes
David Cameron AS foreign secretary and
torpedoing his party chances of even
being competitive at the next election
if you're asking this question you're
suffering from a fundamental
misunderstanding of how a media and
political systems work what happened
over the weekend is that every single
media Outlet in this country went into
overdrive to say that braven's comments
are fueling the far right if you're not
entirely clued up on British political
designations in this country the far
right generally refers to people who are
racist and intolerant towards other
ethnic and religious groups people who
Harbor prej udice against sexual
minorities who consider women inferior
to men and treat them as second class
citizens and use violence to achieve
their political objectives and incite
violence in public in other words the
far right has been on British streets
for weeks now chanting genocidal slogans
calling for Jihad and saying things like
death to all the Jews and Hitler knew
how to deal with these people but that
is of course not who the media mean when
they talk about the far right what they
mean is a small number of football fans
who like to get pissed and get into
scuffles with the police when these
people did turn up this was immediately
taken as evidence the Braverman had
incited a riot because if there's one
thing we know about football Hooligans
is that they all have a subscription to
the times and take inspiration from
powerful Brown women and so it was that
the one politician in the Tory party who
was actually prepared to stand up for
the views of the majority of people in
this country was removed alienating a
significant portion of the party's base
who will now vote for minor parties or
more likely not vote at all in the next
election my congratulations go to labor
leader K Dharma who is playing a Blinder
by staying silent and irrelevant
throughout I for one welcome our new
labor overlords the only hope now is
that they ruin the country so much over
the next four years will finally see
sense and stop punishing politicians for
telling the truth if you enjoy these
videos you can get early access to them
by being a substack subscriber head on
over there
now
[Music]
he